all of this is governed by these
mathematical rules which are very much
like what you would experience if we
were actually inside of a video game
first self-aware entities appeared yeah
that's in a sense of universe waking up
and becoming aware of itself right is
actually as an opportunity if we can
figure out what's going on with black
holes and maybe even get some clues by
looking at them then that can actually
maybe be the master key that can help us
unlock some of the deepest mysteries of
quantum gravity yes
yeah the unified theory of physics a
snap decision you know should we ask
this person on a date or not where it
might come down to just whether one
neuron fired or not in the beginning
triggering a whole cascade of events
could end up with you living in this
city you know be married to this person
with children or be living somewhere
completely different doing something
different I'm quite optimistic that we
can create the really inspiring future
with technology but that's gonna require
winning what I call the wisdom race the
race between the growing power of the
technology exponentially growing power
of the technology with the wisdom with
which you manage this tech but there's a
catch here technology is getting
exponentially more and more powerful
all right and at some point it crosses
the threshold of power we're learning
from mistakes actually goes from being
good strategy to being a really really
bad strategy and I feel we've already
crossed that threshold with nuclear
weapons and we've on the verge of
crossing the threshold with synthetic
biology which can be used fantastically
to improve our health or to create
engineered pandemics and we're totally
gonna cross that threshold with
artificial intelligence if we succeed in
building artificial general intelligence
that can outsmart us you know in all
ways it's not difficult at all
to make the world much much better it's
just that we have our monkey brains and
and most political leaders are very
clueless about technology and in short
it was go into careers with machines
socket and are going to continue to be
bad at four
long time
you